[Music]
good morning everyone I hope you enjoyed
the first part of this day as much as
with it
so we're going to talk about hybrid
monitoring and logging but before we get
started I would love to ask everyone to
stand up for a bit could you please
stand up all right
we're gonna run a very quick survey
those of you running stock driver in
production you may sit down big number
all right those of you using multiple
monitoring and logging tools in
production you may sit down okay and all
the rest those of you running monitoring
across a clouds and some other
environment being on pram or other
clouds you may sit down thank you that
was that was fun okay so here's the
contract over the next half an hour or
so we're gonna talk about what do we
mean by hybrid how do we let you monitor
hybrid environments and at the end we're
going to get you a great walkthrough of
the features of a solution that lets you
do so and we are going to run a demo
with a practical application with this
let's get started so when we talk about
a hybrid environment we're specifically
thinking this very picture right you
have a set up somewhere be it on try and
beat some other cloud and set up in the
cloud like GCP and what you really want
to do is to be able to run your
workloads in the same
way and monitor them in the same way so
ideally that would be the very same
monitoring and logging solutions with
the very same dashboards and very same
alerts that you would apply here and
like here meaning in a cloud and
on-premises so that you can monitor and
see what's happening but even more
convenient would be a situation like
that where you have just one point in
which you can compare how your system is
doing which is specifically important if
you're running the word close with some
spillover between one and the other and
you really want to understand what's
happening more about it in a demo in a
second all right so before we go there
just realize kubernetes wrote this
enormous opportunity of doing exactly
this because the way of abstracting your
workloads on top of the physical
infrastructure ah lets you look at your
deployments and your workloads and the
exact same way so how does the data flow
from the darkest corners of kubernetes
let me get you a very quick walk sure
first kubernetes per se does not have
any sophisticated built-in monitoring
and logging system however many
components depend on monitoring data
right so things like horizontal pod auto
scaling scheduler cube CTL table and
node itself they need metrics so this
has been solved by kubernetes by itself
or itself to something I would call
metrics API this way horizontal Piloto
scaling can actually work using some
internal metrics on the CPU utilization
scheduler can make a reasonable
decisions on where to place today the
thoughts right and cube CTL table get
you the proper information what's really
happening so the metrics API is
implemented by the metric server
metric server is technically scraping
the nodes in the search for the metrics
data that's what's happening there
so let's have a look at the API and you
look at that this super simple right it
actually has three components through
the definition and one is the layout the
level of nodes the second one is at the
level of faults and the third one is
just a list of containers inside of that
bolt and it's really specified only two
pieces of information right a time stamp
a time window and the usage data so this
is what we are collecting this is what
the matrix API is actually getting out
out of corrientes now let's have a
closer look what's happening in the
nodes right well I didn't note you
obviously have a cubelet the cubelet is
consulting with the c advisor to scrape
the data from all of the system
components like docker like ABCD like
all other pieces like system level
faults that need to be monitored and all
of that data is then extract that into
the summary API so through this well we
have a system that is self-sufficient we
call it a core metrics pipeline this is
the system that lets kubernetes run but
in order for you to run the workloads to
run your setup you actually need more
than that and for this you need external
solution we call it third-party
applications right this solutions there
are too many of those they work in one
of two ways they either work in a push
model in which the data and metrics
collected gets written directly to the
monitoring solution order they work in a
pull model where the monitoring solution
is scraping the data from the endpoints
mmm it's hard to say which one is better
your solutions don't work either way and
we're gonna walk you through both of
this so in order to look at the data
you can look at three possible solutions
we're gonna work you here trooper me to
use and stackdriver Prometheus works in
the pool mode stackdriver works in
apportionment
so when you look at the at the structure
of kubernetes you have the nodes on the
bottom with cubelet the key component of
the control of the system then you have
faults and then you have kubernetes
master right at the know level you have
no exporter true node exporter
Prometheus gets the data of like what's
really happening there CPU utilization
amount of memory all of that kind of
setting and then there is pots both as
we just discussed a minute ago get the C
advisor to go get all of the data of how
both are behaving and on top of that you
have all of the natural components of
the kubernetes as a system that are
naturally reported in the primitives for
months and this is everything from the
kubernetes api through the containers
runtime cubelet starters etc all of
these components in in a very natural in
native way get reported by primitive
server that sits on each and every node
so now that we have it let's have a look
at how this is happening in stock
drivers so stock driver has a layer or
three api's the first one is the stuck
driving monitoring API it has a hipster
through which its collecting some of the
data but in fact it also has a structure
I prefer me to use collector so stack
Larry Prometheus collector is capturing
all of the data that from Metis is
scraping from all of the system
components like whatever a number of 500
errors 200 or so and I think that is
happening in the kubernetes layer can
now be accessible through the sack
driver and then there are two more
components one is the metadata API
that rids the data through an agent that
gets deployed on each and every note and
the same deployment our diamond set is
also deploying another four that is
called stackdriver logging agent that is
collecting the logs right so truth is
you have a full set this works in a push
mode and now when you look at the ad
holistically you have for me to use
clients that are on each and every note
and then you have two possible layers
two possible ways you can rate your
metrics data right the top one is the
open source format the Prometheus
collector gets all the data then it uses
its own storage and you can either
present it in either in Prometheus or in
grow fauna I'm sure if you're using any
on-premise solution you're very familiar
with this and then you have stack
drivers stuck there it does the same but
it has the from stacked every Prometheus
collector so it's collects all of the
data from Prometheus but on top of that
is also getting some Electric data and
metadata right and again you can you can
see it in stock driving monitoring UI or
you can graph it in graph honor
so that's it that's the story and now
for the rest of the talk I would like to
invite to stage
JD Velasquez and Shree from Chang who
are going to talk about how we can see
in practice
thank you Jersey hello everybody so we
want to tell you and give you a demo of
how all of this works but before we do
that let's try to orient ourselves a
little bit before we go to the demos
we're in the slides again please we'll
try to orient ourselves a little bit on
what application we have here to give
you a sense of what it is that we're
doing so this is a simple java
application some of you may be familiar
with
it's a pet clinic it's a veterinary
clinic who here has pets come on a lot
more you have pets yes but hopefully
your veterinary clinic is not using this
application to handle everything inside
because it's pretty buggy and has all
the things but we're gonna try to solve
those issues right now so this is again
like I said just a simple place clinic
imagine that you're an employee on this
veterinary clinic and you want to be
able to handle the visits from all of
your customers their pet owners they
have pets and you want to track what
sort of things they're doing the types
of this at the type of veterinarians
they have and and so on so to orient
ourselves further in this application to
really go into a hybrid scenario what
we've implemented here to give you a
sense is an architecture like this we
essentially have a cluster that has been
deployed on prem kubernetes cluster we
have four micro services here doing what
they're supposed to do managing
customers managing the visits managing
the veterinarian soon and in general and
the same cluster we have actually
deployed on kubernetes engine on GCP and
both of those clusters communicate with
the data source which is cloud spanner
okay so that's essentially the app very
simple now let's go to the demo now and
we'll we'll see this in action
specifically so in you know just to
orient ourselves a little bit further
and started generate a little traffic to
this app let's go in and use it just a
bit let's list the set of owners that
may exist already this business may not
be doing very well right now since it
has a no owners are very few of course
it's a live demo what could go wrong
there we go
okay so we have a few owners already
what we can do is
let's add a new pet to one of those
owners so we get a sense of the
different services what they do let's
add a new pet to this particular one
let's give it a name we of course want
to know the date of birth for that pet
and then one type of pet I prefer dogs
but you know of course lots of cats now
we can add visits we see that some of
the pets for this owner they were
already visited the clinic
and do some things this new pet we're
gonna take them in for the first exam
it's a physical exam and that's it you
know we may ask you of course to go in
and generate so traffic for this but
instead of doing that let us just
generate a little bit of more traffic
right now the idea here so of course we
want to scale up things so that we can
do some of the troubleshooting scenarios
so we just are going to our on pram
cluster and as you see here we're just
executing a scaling command and we're
just scaling up that on-prem cluster now
we did that on one side let's do it now
on the gk cluster inform kubernetes
engine so let's go to our cloud console
let's connect to the cluster and when we
do there we see our cloud shell let's
get all of our credentials properly and
now what we want to do is run the same
command we're gonna scale up the
kubernetes engine cluster so this is
essentially what we need to do right
just to generate some traffic here and
it would take maybe another few seconds
or so there we go
now both clusters should be getting some
traffic now this is internally but the
same thing you might as well be
generating that traffic for us now what
we want to do is what happens how do we
get the type of observability you need
to see your kubernetes environment
particularly in a hybrid scenario so you
can do a couple of things if you're you
know if you're starting on prem most
likely you're like many of us will be
using open source software so very
likely you're probably using prometheus
and Ravana if you want to get metrics
and do alerts and maybe some
visualizations that you can configure
and so on and that's exactly what we're
doing here
now if you want to get some blogs as
well you may be using elasticsearch or
some other solution and maybe you want
other signals so maybe a bunch of other
tools when URI was asking you you know
those of you who actually have many
tools
large majority of you that actually
stayed up and then came down when you
know to actually use many tools all
together to get this observability so
let's go to our Prometheus and graph an
ax instance on Prem
the one we set up this actually took
very little configuration all of these
solutions are available on our GCP
marketplace and you can just you know
readily use it color like a one-click
type of setup and get those running so
what we will do and just cheating here a
little bit to make sure that we get the
right password let's log into that graph
Anna instance that we have set up for on
Prem and as that comes in okay perfect
that's our Agra fauna instance now out
of a box with these type of solutions
you get definitely some type of
observability if we look at the list of
things here we have several dashboards
you may look at your clusters your
namespaces your pods and so forth let's
go specifically to our cluster one to
get some notion of health that may exist
here so now you can see some particular
scorecards and definitely we see that
traffic actually spiked up a bit so our
scaling is working and then down below
we have some metrics that we could then
further prove is it based on namespaces
I could go specifically to one of the
namespaces we go to the default one and
then from there then we can drill down
into pods and maybe we have a dozen
apart or so for this particular app here
and then we can take a look at you know
more of those metrics CPU utilization
the limits requests and so forth maybe
the same thing for memory and so on so
this is way in which you if you're using
open source and Prometheus and Ravana
you would get that type of basic
observability you need for your on-prem
cluster but we're talking about hybrid
so you want to do the same for your
kubernetes engine now there's now you
know you can have a do-it-yourself type
of solution to do multi cluster
monitoring but out of the box you really
must create a separate graph on an
instance and put it on your kubernetes
engine side and so let's do that
precisely why don't we go to our cloud
console and then run the commands we
need and then logging into our graph an
instance for kubernetes engine now a
good thing of course I can do I can
transfer all my dashboard configurations
and then we'll be there
so we can see the same thing we have all
the same type of dashboards so let's do
the same thing with it for the other one
same type of scorecard and we'll see the
profile in a minute hopefully the
traffic is working in the same way and
yeah we see slightly different pattern
but traffic is also scaling up on the
kubernetes engine and the same thing we
can scale down you know drill down
further on the default namespace go to a
pod again the tape same type of
observability that you would get you can
configure these dashboards as you wish
and then get something that meets your
needs specifically now as I said earlier
many of you actually are using many
different tools to get the type of
observability you need and what we've
heard from many of you who actually is
that you don't want to use that many
tools that you wants a single unified
solution to observe and get you know do
proper monitoring and logging of your
kubernetes environment no matter what it
runs now whether it's running on on-prem
or running on on on GCP on kubernetes
engine or even if you're running that
kubernetes deployment on a GCE instance
or maybe even on a VM instance on
another cloud provider you still want to
have that single place where you can
monitor all of these things so this is
where start driver kubernetes monitoring
comes in
so stock traffic kubernetes monitoring
gives you very rich and comprehensive
observer ability for your kubernetes
environment no matter where it runs and
what it does is actually integrates
metrics and logs and events and metadata
in a single place so that you don't have
to be going to different tools to try to
get that observability precisely and so
let us see how this works and in action
if we can go to stack driver kubernetes
monitoring which you can do by selecting
the monitoring link on your cloud
console that takes you to the stack
driver monitoring console here and from
there we're gonna choose the resources
menu and then go directly to the
kubernetes monitoring console so this is
a product which just announced briefly
and it's in beta right now and so we'd
love for you to use it and give us your
feedback so first this is the stock
driver kuben in is monitoring console
let's orient ourselves a little bit here
so
first you see the event widget on the
top that allows you essentially to get
information from different events
particularly things that may be of
interest or your kubernetes environment
it is actually a heat map so you have
the more solid lines it's because
there's a higher frequency of events and
the idea is for you to correlate those
events with the state of your cluster
down below now in the pane below
precisely you see the set of clusters
now from the start notice that we
already have observer ability of the two
clusters our on-prem cluster is already
there and our gke cluster is also there
now for deploying the the stack travel
agents on the on frame cluster it's
really simple you just follow a set of
instructions and it's done so out of the
box you get rich observability for your
hybrid multi cluster environment now
notice also that here in this scenario
we surface a lot of you know key
information for you type of including
the number of incidents pods that are
ready memory and CPU utilization with
respect to your resources and the limits
that you have configured notice as well
that you've actually even though
kubernetes doesn't have a hierarchy per
se we're taking advantage of kubernetes
labels to give you a pre curated
hierarchies that may be useful for you
depending on the roles that you may have
so if you're on an SRE and operator for
instance you may want to look at the
state of your infrastructure you want to
make sure that your nodes are healthy
and performant so that's what we may be
doing here but if you're a developer you
may actually want to be and of course we
want to for you to focus on writing your
code and look at your application so you
may be a more interested in and looking
at it from the perspective of your
deployments or your services
particularly so we can drill down from a
cluster to a namespace to the services
that you want notice as well that we're
doing this you can actually drill down
all the way from your cluster in all of
these views all the way down to a
container and for each of these
kubernetes objects you get very rich
information so for instance I can go and
inspect let's inspect a part right now
and I immediately get several metrics I
know that my pot is ready and is running
if there's any incidents open I can see
it right there and then I start to get
some information on my metrics like CPU
memory
and so on all the way down and notice
that in the same place as we moved in
your network usage you'll find that we
also include logs so that goes back
again to this idea of true and rich
observability trying to increase the
signals that are available to you at the
right context in the right time and in
the and right kubernetes component so
they it is easier for you to speed your
root cause analysis when you're trying
to resolve an incident or to find things
when you're just doing proactive
monitoring so we see snippets of logs
all right here and I could even go deep
down into logging to get more details
here now this is very much the the
self-contained kubernetes monitoring but
of course you can use it with all the
other features that stack driver has
here as you mentioned before that stack
Robert already has a Prometheus
collector so if you have a Prometheus
instrumentation already you can just
have that with stack driver all your
metrics will be ingested without a
change and if you're not using any
premises
instrumentation yet but you want to get
access to a third party metrics let's
say you have you're using Kafka rabbitmq
or anything else on on your app then you
can ingest those via Prometheus and
they'll be ready in stock driver so the
way we do that is if you want to inspect
those metrics we can create custom
charts and custom dashboards or you
could go to a metrics Explorer which is
exactly the way you do on demand type of
inspection so here we can inspect all of
our kubernetes objects and all the
metrics that are available to you I can
look at all the Prometheus metrics you
see the autocomplete already expanding
on all the Prometheus metrics this is a
Java app so let's let's look into one
particularly let's do the JVM memory use
bytes to get a sense here so all right
there we go so lots of signals but you
know fast and available you get a sense
for what we have here another good thing
is that we've added a lot of dimensions
to these metrics so you can filter and
group by a lot of metadata including
kubernetes labels and user-defined
labels so let's try to do some here
let's filter by service name and the
service name we can do notice that you
get actually an autocomplete of all the
values that apply to that label let's do
the API gateway apply that ok that's
still a lot of signals but a little bit
better
we could still group by and aggregate
may be creative 95th percentile or
some sort but what we have here is maybe
the easiest thing would be maybe do
outlier mode we can then check the the
top-end objects that are interests so
why do we do the top five containers by
JVM memory use bytes use memory bytes so
that we have it so that rapidly you can
easily develop a hypotheses or just
inspect on demand and look at particular
metrics for any of your kubernetes
components and metrics available so this
wraps up essentially this proactive type
of monitoring now all the other features
in stock driver including mostly
condition alerting and everything else
are available to you including what you
may have seen earlier in the keynote
when it's a ready for public consumption
and all the service monitoring stuff and
integration with easter and so on so
that's essentially for the the main
console and kubernetes monitoring I'm
going to switch with Churchill now so
that he can take us through a
troubleshooting scenario all right
thanks JD so Lisa so Tom the tech lead
of a company's monitoring so I want to
demo a troubleshooting scenario so as a
software engineer or operation engineer
one of the thing the common scenario you
will probably encounter a lot in your
daily work is when your application
receiving a high volume of traffic your
application become less responsive or
slow and so this is the scenario so as
to recall it's like when JD is doing his
demo we generate some traffic against
post kubernetes engine cluster and the
open cluster and while you are watching
the previous demo I as an uncle engineer
has been paged by this incident by this
traffic so as you can see here from the
email I have already received a lot it's
like my some of my container are written
into many 500 some of my services are
returning too many five hundreds so and
in this email report at the bottom it
gives me a view incident link which
redirect me to stack driver incident
page so as you can see here so this is
like we our services are returning to
many 500 this is concerning because our
customer may experiencing is
experiencing this outage
so I would like to resolve this incident
as soon as possible let's go to the
custom dashboard for the my hybrid pack
clinic app this is a custom dashboard I
predefined before he has some chance for
some interesting metrics I care the most
for my pack linic application for
example from the on the first row there
are two charts for HTTP request and HTTP
error rates and since this is a java
application so i also draw to charge for
JVM metrics which is collected and
exploited by Prometheus besides there I
also draw something like CPU limit
utilization and memory utilization and
some container restart and something
else so by looking at this cousin - PO
is to give me a very good understanding
about what my hybrid application what's
their current state first let's look at
the first chart as you can see both my
kubernetes engine cluster and my Oberon
Custer are receiving a reasonable amount
of traffic like both around 300 this is
working as intended because this one my
load balancer conflicts I put a
half-and-half weight on both cluster if
we look at the second chart we can see
all of my 500 arrows are all coming from
on Prem cluster it already gives me a
very strong signal that something is
wrong it's in my own parent cluster as a
natural reaction and they want to dive
deeper into the Umbra encruster and
figure out what's happening there but
our si best practice tell me why should
my tea gate and contain the issue first
and the best choice here is to drain my
own brain cursor and failover is traffic
to somewhere else and since I have to
cluster failing over to Cuba Nanjing is
a natural choice but before I do that I
want to ensure the additional safety I
want to make sure my kubernetes engine
cluster can sustain the load if y boy
so let's go to the kubernetes monitoring
UI and let's take a look at the
infrastructure and expand the kubernetes
engine cluster
so as you can see there are six nodes
there some of them are reasonably busy
like you can see 42 percent utilized 43
but some of them are quite empty so this
gives me a confidence that even I fail
over my trophy to kubernetes engine it
can sustain so let's go ahead and do it
so in this criminal 3d world skilled
manually drained on foreign caster by
scaling done and in the same time same
time we will switch back to closure for
my company's engine cluster and here we
will scale manually scheduled up to fail
over the traffic so this step will
probably take about 1 or 2 minutes when
we asked which in traffic from one
cluster to another cluster let's go back
to the hybrid dashboard and see what we
can observe there so as you can see here
so our own prank has trophy has already
mean drop and then the 500 ray is also
dropping and in a moment later we will
see the kubernetes engine cluster
receiving more traffic so this gives you
a little bit more time so so in the real
Wars like training the trophy will take
some time
ok so let's refresh again
okay so let's fog first one what I can
see where you can go yep
as you can see here so our equipment is
engine caster has receiving more traffic
and you will keep going up so I think in
this moment as on co engineer I'm fairly
I'm reasonably confident that the issue
has been mitigating and content now next
step for me is to figure out what's
happening in this Lancaster to prevent
me to resolve it and prevent it from
happening again let's go to kubernetes
UI monitoring UI and switch to service
tab and that's open as you can see here
we have an incident open incident con :
that can give you an insight like what
what's the entity that has the most
issues and then you can help us drill
down and identify where we should pay
attention to so we can further go down
to the before namespace and there will
be the API gateway it's like is the
thing they will have the issue
so let's inspect the part of API gateway
so as you can see here so for the first
choice container is that it doesn't have
any restart it means probably my
container is healthy and memory
utilization is in a reasonable usage and
CPU utilization is high about 80 percent
but it is reasonable because we are
sending a lot of traffic and it is not
crazy it's not like out of the pantry so
it doesn't sense where it suspicious
let's scroll down and a storage usage is
flat and network usage is high because
the same we are receiving a lot of
traffic and so till now if looking at
the system matrix it doesn't help us
anything like suspicious because it
seems like my company's application
company's infrastructure is running
healthy we would then walk up II the
root cause at this moment the log will
help us a lot as you can see here from
the lock rates we are receiving a lot of
an unreasonable amount of error logs
Oh from what you have been as you can
see that's about 40% of arrow lock has
been written while the arena incidents
this is like it's a very good signal for
me to make maybe and my app is returning
some it has some back and then restoring
some arrows as you can see from the lock
snippet below we already see some like
runtime exception has been thrown by my
java application I want to understand a
little bit more details let's click on
the go to login link and then go to
stack driver logs viewer to have a more
detailed look so this link will redirect
me through the lochs viewer with the
future specifically for this single port
and restrict it to the time that were
these instant happen that matters the
most to me as you can read from here
there are thousands of occurrence of
this runtime exception has been thrown
if we open one of them we can see the
error message site unable to fetch
detail for owner one which is a runtime
exception and it is a stack trace it
could give us a very good understanding
where this excess bein has been thrown
if we scroll down we can see like this
so this API gateway controller let's see
yeah this API gateway controller Java
file it in line 54 is throwing this
arrow and I want to understand what why
this arrow has been thrown let's go to
code so what it is doing here is that he
was search for this API gateway Java
file because that's what stack trace has
tell us and let's go to the line 54 or
use like search so as you can see here
there are three lines very problematic
somebody has ADD these three lines of
code to throw 500 after tossing a coin
so this is the where my code has a back
and so I'm going to so now identify the
root cause the thing for me next step is
to fix the back redeploy the app to um
foreign cluster
and renowned foreign hostile so my
application will be back to normal I'm
we are not going to do this here but
just to illustrate the idea so as you
can see from this arrow troubleshooting
scenario stackdriver kubernetes
monitoring it integrates metrics logs
metadata and events it can give you the
observability you need to monitor and
troubleshoot your hybrid kubernetes
application and let's switch back to
slice and so if we if you want to know a
little bit more about how you want to
observe and troubleshoot your hybrid
application and how to provision your
kubernetes application better
here are some related talk you can
attend and now let's welcome back our
teammates Jessie and JD now it's we open
up for questions and maybe the time is
very limited if you have more question
we can go to the hallway thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]